you know when you're in the doctors and
you wait and you're there like before
it's 2 30 you go there's 2 30 and then
they you don't get seen till like 3 15.
and it's like then don't have a point
because here's the thing she was just
like just walk over there they'll take
you and i'm like well then what the [ __ ]
are we doing with these appointments i'm
always waiting for one minute and then i
realize when i get there dude it's
because of guys like me
because i'm walking in on the side and i
got to [ __ ] they need to be better at
it is what i'm saying
i walked over there there were like
eight people in line with appointments
and like we'll get to you and now i felt
bad
so i'm there
and i'm waiting to do it and everyone's
[ __ ] really nice you know because
they should be by the way because you're
going under the knife i didn't do it yet
but i know i have to so
and then she said that the the person
behind the the desk was like
uh mr dalia can you come here
i need to ask you something and i walked
over and i was like what the [ __ ] like
it has to be in private because you know
medical stuff is real dicey so i walk up
and she's like when's the dude over here
surgery and i and i told her which i
don't even know why it says i don't even
tell you guys i don't know why it's a
secret but like i feel like it's a
secret i can't tell people and then i
told her and then she was like okay
thanks a lot and then [ __ ] went back
and i sat down dude and i'm gonna send
you a picture of this okay i'm gonna
send you a picture of this
because i took a picture of this because
when it happened i needed to document it
okay i needed to document it
because i wanted to and i did it for the
podcast all right and i also texted
friends about this now i've told you
stories like this before but it happened
again and it happens to me more than
anybody and i don't know why it might be
because i'm a spry tall drink of water
it might be because i sit down like bon
jovi it might be because i [ __ ] relax
like a praying mantis but i'm chilling
right and i'm waiting and i'm waiting
too long and i want to relax so what do
i do i make it my home dude when i want
to relax and when things are taking too
long i make [ __ ] my home and sometimes i
sit badly and by badly i mean good okay
that's what i mean because if you're
sitting the way you want to you're being
you and you know what if you're being
you you're welcome hey everyone around
me you're welcome you get the real me my
walls are down and this is what you get
congratulations all right and i like
when people are the real them because i
don't want any [ __ ] secrets if
somebody's snooping around not being
themselves then what happens i don't
know who i'm dealing with and i can get
stabbed in the back
okay
so
i'm sitting you like one time when i was
younger i was trying to get financed for
this movie i was trying to produce and i
sat down on the couch and i sat down
real relaxed and afterwards my producing
partner said yo i don't know if you
should sit like that and i said why he
said because it's kind of disrespectful
and i'm like no it's not i'm just
chilling i'm like yeah but we wanted
money from those people and i'm like
yeah but you know i don't think it
matters that much and then later on like
a year later he said yo i want to
apologize for that day i said you
shouldn't sit like that i actually found
i was reading this thing uh in some
[ __ ] book that if you have the balls
to sit the way you want and not
respectful then people feel like they
need you and that probably helped us get
the funding for movie because guess what
we did get the funding for the [ __ ]
movie dude
anyway that's neither here nor there
because now i'm here at this [ __ ]
post-op chest x-ray thing
and i do the [ __ ] bon jovi right i
put my foot up and i don't put it on a
chair i put it on a
uh i'll put the picture up right here
but i put it on the the
for those of you listening i put it on
the armrest of the chair and by the way
the arm when i say arm rest it's very
light it's a very light armrest it's
it's like a [ __ ] thin it's not like a
king and a queen would sit here it's a
[ __ ] chair that they got for 15
because they needed to get 25 of them
right
they got it at like you know
surgeryemporium.com
and uh they got a deal on them and i'm
just kicking it dude and i'm the only
one there i'm the only one there now
there's no there may be one other person
in the room waiting
and this lady comes out and
she's a hundred
okay
as in years old she's a hundred
all right she's a little bit more
beautiful then but looks like the crypt
keeper she's
a hundred all right dressed in gucci
because we're in beverly hills
however
she's a year older than 99. she looks so
close do you know what i'm talking about
now i wish the best for you
but you're so close
okay
i hope things work out for you for as
long as you want but
you're so close
you're knocking
and here i am just being a spry [ __ ]
praying mantis just chilling it
right and i'm chilling it hard just
it's not like i'm aggressively putting
my foot on the arm chair it's like i
my leg
happens to be draped over this [ __ ]
thing okay
and this lady comes in and she's one of
those 100 year old that's like hey hey
how you doing hey hey like one of these
one of those people that you
see coming from a mile away and you
think oh dude i want to be like that
when i'm that age but then very quickly
turn it in your mind to oh i bet that
person makes other people's lives a
living hell
right like people that they actually
know
so
she says you know i gotta tell you to
the people behind the to the people
working there she says
the doctors here are a one they're just
so great and i'm like wow what a nice
lady who the [ __ ] walks to the front and
compliments doctors
and they're like oh yeah they are the
best aren't they and she says every time
i come here it's such a pleasant
experience and then the ladies behind
the counter say well yeah you know she
says okay well i'll see you another oh
she says um she says uh the doctors are
just great and then she says you on the
other hand and they start laughing they
all start laughing and they're joking
and i'm like not only is this lady nice
she's got humor dude
she's a hundred she's knocking she's so
close but she's also keeping it
sarcastic
this is great
so maybe i was wrong about her making
people's lives a living hell and you
know me just sitting down being a
[ __ ] belly-up praying mantis
then she looks over at me
and she's looking too long
and i feel it
i don't look at her but i feel it you
know
and then she says
to the ladies behind the counter
this gentleman has his feet on the
furniture
and that's when my
that's what my blood does something
different doesn't it
it was a certain temperature but now
what's it doing
it's bubbling
but you know what maybe she's riding
that sarcasm that sarcasm wave right
maybe that's what she's doing so she
says this gentleman has his foot on the
table and they laugh
and i laugh
and i look at her and i say well i can
take it down if you'd like and she said
i think it would be a good idea if you
took your feet off the furniture
so now we're politicians that want
something different right
that's like the kind of thing we are
like you have to still meet with
lobbyists but we want something
different but we're cordial and we're
smiling but we're not happy because we
want something different
and i'm furious
so this is what i did i said okay
and left my foot there the whole time
i did it dude whoa i don't know what's
winning or losing in that situation but
i told her i would do it and then didn't
and she didn't [ __ ] say [ __ ] after
that dude
uh bothers me when people are just like
like let me live dude
like what what do you
this was a patient dude i told it to
kristen and she was like don't be mean
and then she found out later when i was
talking about it it was a patient she
was like she didn't even work there and
i was like yes exactly if you work there
that's one thing then i get it it's
annoying but okay hey look it's your
place your rules this [ __ ] chick was
getting some surgery done
she was in her pre-op too i think you
need your feet off the man [ __ ] mind
your own business dude you're so close
be happy let people live dude
i don't understand the people that don't
let people live i don't understand it
crazy
crazy
crazy
crazy
crazy
[Music]